[Música]
boa tarde meu nome é luis echeverría tem
uma sede do 5º ano e hoje eu vou falar
para vocês sobre a arquitetura
sustentável
estava em casa distraída assistindo um
filme quando ouvi um barulho na porta de
entrada
fiquei com medo e ao mesmo tempo muita
curiosidade abrir a porta e lá estava
ele todo vermelho
um jornal de 2050
o futuro seria uma catástrofe
manchete a falta de água potável matar
uma criança a cada 15 segundos e os
recursos naturais estão se esgotando
muito rápido mas será que podemos dar
essa história como com arquitetura
sustentável
mas o que é é uma maneira de projetar e
construir de forma sustentável reduzindo
o impacto ambiental e nos próximos dias
lights e mostrar pra vocês a minha casa
sustentável que os meus pais estão
projetando uma casa sustentável usar a
água de maneira econômica
o aproveitamento da água da chuva ea
utilização em descarga irrigação de
lavagem de peso o tratamento da água
cinza que o tratamento de águas
residuais dos chuveiros valores lavar
roupa ea cisterna subterrânea que o
armazenamento da água de chuva coletada
vi uma casa sustentável usar a energia
de forma eficiente com aquecimento solar
que o aquecimento da água através da
energia solar com a iluminação natural
que a redução do consumo de energia
elétrica ea iluminação artificial que é
o uso de lâmpadas econômicas de led uma
casa sustentável usa materiais
reciclados
lá vem sua construção com os
investimentos que a utilização de
pastilhas por exemplo feitas de garrafa
pet
o reboco de terra que a matéria prima
natural 100% reciclável ea madeira de
demolição que a madeira de uma casa que
foi demolida e vai ser reutilizada uma
casa sustentável usar ao máximo os
recursos naturais como a ventilação
natural que deixa sua casa fresquinha no
verão e quente no inverno o telhado ea
parede verde que controlam a temperatura
interna e melhoram a qualidade do ar ea
horta que a produção de alimentos para
consumo próprio
uma casa sustentável recicla reduzir e
reuso seus resíduos com a compostagem
que a produção de adubo através do lixo
orgânico ea separação do lixo reciclável
entre outros
agora ouvi um barulho na porta de
entrada novamente mas ciente de que
poderia fazer para melhorar o mundo
abrir a porta sem ter medo e lá estava
ele todo verdinho no jornal 2050
o futuro seria maravilhoso manchete
parcerias parceria com cientistas de
israel garante água potável para toda a
população
graças ao reuso e a dessalinização eu
vou fazer a minha parte
e você o que pode fazer para melhorar o
futuro e não que ele seja daquele jeito
vermelho gentileza gera gentileza
se você foi gentil com a natureza é
gentil com você
muito obrigada